عند تخطيط للسفر الى دوله تختلف عملتها عن
تلك المتداوله في بلدك طبيعي انك ستضطر
الى التعامل مع رسوم غير متوقعه خلال
الرحله وسائل الدفع والتكاليف مختلفه عند
السفر ويحتار المسافر ايها يستخدم
والاتخاذ القرار المناسب يجب فهم مزايا
وعيوب كل خيار من خيارات صرف العملات
بالفعل تحويل العمله النقديه مشاهدينا الى
عمله اخرى او استخدام بطاقات الائتمان او
حتى الشيكات تحويل العمله قبل ولا بعد
الوصول طبعا وايضا اسئله مثل اللجوء الى
مكاتب الصرف في المطارات ام الشركات
شركات الصرافه الخاصه كلها اسئله مهمه في
هذا الاطار للاجابه على كل هذه الاسئله
لنتعرف على افضل طرق تحويل العملات عند
السفر
الاستوديو معانا مشاهدينا الخبير
الاقتصادي عبد العظيم الاموي اهلا بك
استاذ عبد العظيم
هذا موضوع الحقيقه بالنسبه الي يعني كانه
لغه صينيه لاني
ما بعرف ايمتى لازم اصرف شو لازم اصرف هل
استخدم العمله المحليه بالبلد اللي انا
رايحه عليها ولا عمله البلد اللي انا جاي
منها خلينا نبلش بدايه هلا لما نسافر
نقوم باي عمليه تسوق واردنا ان نستخدم
بدايه البطاقات الائتمانيه وبسالونا هل
بتحبوا انه نقتطع المبلغ
بعمله بلدك الاصلي او بالدولار مثلا او
العمله المحليه شو هو الخيار الافضل صباح
الخير صباح الخير استاذ المشاهدين حياك
الله هو طبعا هذا سؤال يعني دائما
الخطر الاكبر هو انه انت تتكبد نفقات اكبر
لانه تحويل العمله فيه شكين فيه هو سعر
الصرف وفيه رسوم رسوم التحويل
فبرضو الموضوع مرتبط بكثير من الخطه السفر
نفسها لانه احيانا انت تضطر الى ان تقوم
بعمليه الصرف قبل السفر وتحمل معك نقود
وحيانا الجهه الوجهه اللي انت ذاهب اليها
ربما يكون ايضا حمل الاموال نفسه خطر عليك
فبالتالي الامر يعني هو يعتمد على كثير من
العوامل ولكن اذا اخذنا اجمالا انه انت
ذاهب الى وجهها جيده ما فيها مشكله تحتاج
يمكن ان تتحمل ان تحمل اموال فيفضل ان
تقوم بعمليه تحديد الميزانيه وما تحتاجه
من المال مسبقا ويفضل ايضا ان تقوم بصرف
المبلغ في البنك الذي تتعامل معه في بلدك
في بلدك يعني مش في بلد اللي انت متجه
اليه اذا امر مثلا تحويل عادي مثلا دولار
درهم دولار درهم يورو عملات يعني عملات
وعالميه ولكن عندما تكون هنالك مشكله في
الناس يعني صرف العمله الاخرى ايضا انت
انت لا تعرف سعر الصرف بشكل جيد
البطاقات نفسها ربما لا تكون مستخدمه هناك
ربما يكون فقط الذي يستخدم الماستر
والفيزا
انت عندك بطاقه ثانيه فالامر ايضا فيه
كثير من النقاط التي يجب ان تستوي فيها
ولكن الرسوم هي الرسوم يعني طيب سيد عبد
العظيم اليوم
لما تحب تروح الى بلد معين عندك خيار منه
انت والله اليوم عرفت انه سعر العمله في
هذه البلد نزل فبالتالي انا اروح اخذ هذا
المبلغ اللي انا حابب اني اسافر اقعد لي
اسبوعين ثلاثه في هذا البلد اروح احاول
اني اغير العمله في محلات الصرافه او محل
الصرافه البعض يقول لي هذه العمله غير
متوفره البعض الاخر قد يطلب اكثر من سعر
الصرف ما الذي افعله هل اغير الى مثلا
الدولار او اليورو واروح اغير في هذا
البلد ام لا هذه سؤال ممتاز جدا يحصل
معانا السنه اللي فاتت السنه اللي فاتت
اليورو كان يعادلا للدولار صحيح في ذلك
الوقت كان انا اتذكر كان قبل يمكن ثلاثه
شهور قبل الصيف
فكثير من الناس اللي كانوا منتبهين اشتروا
هنا في الامارات
وكانوا ذاهبين الى وجهات اوروبيه فكانوا
يشتروا باسعار رخيصه
وعندما حان وقت السفر
حملوا معهم اليورو وكان القوه الشرائيه
ارتفعت نتيجه ارتفاع سعره لذلك الوقت ايضا
الامر
منقدرش نعرف اذا راح يطلع تطلع قيمه هذه
العمله ولا لا قبل ما ننهي بس انت ما
جاوبني على سؤالي لما استخدم البطاقه
الائتمانيه في اي دوله اخرى غير بلدي او
المنطقه اللي انا جاي منها واللي انا
ساكنه فيها ادفع
بعمله المحليه ولا بالدولار ولا العمله
المحليه للبلد اللي انا فيها هو ان تدفع
بنفس العمله التي خرجت بها البطاقه لانها
بتكون معروفه
بالدرهم افضل لانه ايضا اذا اخذتي انت
عاوزه تعملي ثلاثه مراحل انت بتصرفي من
الدرهم للدولار الى العمله الرقم ثلاثه
نشكر خلاص للاسف انتهى وقتنا يعني الحقيقه
كنا حابين ناخذ معلومات اكثر الخبيره
الاقتصاديه عبد العظيم الاموي كان معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات